The introduction of Machine Learning
as an EMR technology is I think,
potentially a key development.
If EMR's are to adapt to physicians,
they must have some
understanding of what they do.
To explore that further,
we'll now turn to a second commercial
EMR, Praxis by Infor-Med Corporation.
PRAXIS using machine learning and
each physician user trains it
as they see the common
problems in their practice.
Which it identifies based on the
physicians entry of the clinical finding
most specific for each problem.
Over time PRAXIS learned how that
physician usually treats each problem
and as shown here.
Presents a note based on
the most similar past patients.
Each phrase is what Praxis
calls a clinical concept.
But these are not encoded into
SNOMED CT or any other data standard.
They are text descriptions as
defined by each physician.
To avoid the erroneous default
value problem we discussed earlier.
The physician must click on each
clinical concept to confirm
and, or edited.
This one has been clicked on and the
physician can then edit the number of
days to whatever is appropriate for
that patient.